what would you do if I sang attitude
would you stand up and walk out on me
lay enemy Oh eaters then I'll sing you a
song I will try not to say
[Music]
I'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is known as the get over here dance
commonly referred to as a scorpion and
for those of you who don't remember that
there probably because you picked the
female fighter in mortal combat one of
the female fighters and you lost I hope
that you will reverse sexism the time
served you well Oh katana was awful
producing with me in video studio as
always as Jared who is not gay follow
him on Twitter at not gay Jared me a
desk rider with your comments questions
conclusions photoshop's I fulfill my
legal obligations riding on conclusions
we get we're good
actually Morgan Jr doing well she's
gotta keep for a cartoon character
katana yeah yeah I know I would take I
would take the instruction manual to my
bedroom must and stopped up no not very
hey we have market floss coming up this
you're watching this on YouTube right
now this is the week free trial for not
mug Club memory this is what you're
missing out on every single day we do a
daily show so lateral credit.com slash
month Club for those who do not yet
support the content and we need you out
there supporting it stefan molyneux
talked about that last week YouTube is
trying to close the walls and on
conservatives because we own this joint
we wanted you see it listen if you don't
join the Mudd Club even after this free
week we're still gonna do the free show
on Thursdays you're still gonna get a
free clip every day so don't worry no
there isn't going to be less content
just this week we are giving you more
mark Duplass that'll be a great
conversation back on the show and our
show then he went on Ruben and did work
with Glenn back yeah yeah we'll be
talking about Donald Trump Clint
Eastwood we'll be talking about adult
films later on I there's no segue to it
right now okay over the weekend I was in
the big story Donald Trump visited Saudi
Arabia and Israel of course he was
praised he was criticized both for kind
of the pre snippets of the speech I
think we can see him here at the Wailing
Wall he went to the Wailing Wall and
obviously was very moved he said it's a
great wall a fantastic wall but if it
were his Hamas would have paid for it
there was there was a lot of criticism
we'll talk about that but he did he did
he talked about being really moved by
the Wailing Wall as a matter of fact he
said that we should incorporate it in
the United States at our border a to
honor those Americans with Jewish
heritage and B it would confuse the hell
out of the Mexican
other
why do you use a mattock huh check the
moon I know
yo D you still bury me he go Tennyson
look you got the short another stick
poor guy even see it coming over that
wall okay so Donald Trump in in in Saudi
Arabia we actually posted a snippet of
the speech beforehand at la Rosa Qatar
calm and it seemed really harsh a real
turn from Obama's rhetoric on terrorism
a lot of people thought that he softened
it when he was there because he said
Islam was one of the world's greatest
religions first of all what were your
takes on this I was happy to see the
u.s. kind of take a lead he did call him
out while he was there I watched his
speech when it was given yeah and he
said that he said it was among the great
faiths of the world so yeah I call it
the greatest which it's not that you
can't go there and just poke the bear a
hole in the ground I know that to be
true yes you have to be somewhat
diplomatic well I mean somewhat
diplomatic but he was obviously talking
before the election saying if you want
to look into 9/11 I was criticizing
Barack Obama and Iraq he said it was the
Saudis you know who carried on and now
the Saudis did not carry out 9/11 many
of the terrorists were from Saudi Arabia
and the problem is that you know Saudi
Arabia kind of turned a blind eye in
Saudi Arabia has shielded organizations
who sponsor terror but it's not all that
different from from us and care it's
true that they have done more than some
countries have in that region to weed
out and actually have arrested and
killed that is right or maybe in the
resurrection too so they are they do a
lot of crappy stuff but they're moving
in the right direction we want to keep
that going I was excited to see him call
and say hey look
out of your temples I don't replace the
worship out of everywhere just drive
these the tear the extremists out here
and you need you from these out region
that we're in look at this place also by
the way the drug do not give you a limit
the right to drive it's bad it's bad bad
well put a moral ah go this guy knows he
thinks it's a cabbie so this is
something yeah I think it was overall
pretty good yeah I really do I think
overall it was it was better than of
course the media would make it out to be
maybe not as successful as some of his
some of his supporters who said he's
gonna he's gonna just take it to Saudi
Arabia in Islam the guy we're seeing a
more diplomatic Trump there so I think
in the wake of last week that's a good
thing cultural appropriation this week
an outrage there was an adult homosexual
film called digeridoo me seen by us
published friend calm it featured two
actors effectively using the aboriginal
instrument as an enormous sexual
apparatus and critics online they lashed
out at the scene saying that it's
disrespectful mostly to the didgeridoo
which plays a part in the aboriginal
spiritual life to Vision Quest they're
not I just understand what kind of a
human being watching this yeah has the
nerve to suddenly claim the moral
hydride of our cultural appropriation
and now that has no shame in doing it
publicly for this but I'll watch there
watching gay pornography
they were fine with the upside down wine
bottles they can you believe that they
did with the didgeridoo hey it looks
like you're watching gay porn over there
but that's beside the point
and then listen they were not respecting
Aboriginal culture you know native
Australia and culture we've talked about
the outrage with this and further
complaints arose when they ran a black
light over the smallpox blankets and
well and they wanted you know we talked
about Native Americans Aboriginal
culture in Australia there's there are a
lot of similarities so they wanted but
unavailable for comment was the Indian
from the Village People because he's
dead from AIDS yeah
always too soon tying it back I don't
think it's ever too soon all right
listen in other news I just get a
cultural appropriation people are
outraged on a second I get that you want
to virtue single and be outraged people
who are on Twitter like Jesus they
realize that their parents can read
their Twitter for the rest of their life
their parents were like shut up you talk
you talk about the one who went to
Harvard no the one who tweets about
digeridoo me that one pretty new
character zero self-awareness man good
luck getting a job at a bank they're
gonna Google you and is what is this
didgeridoo oh my god he's fired so this
is something I've talked about it's
making the rounds everywhere everyone
has seen this video if you haven't we're
going to show it to you I've had a bit
in stand up for a long time about why
sea lions sea otters are just the PETA
are they're just wrong animals are the
worst things in the planet people like
to act as though they're somehow nicer
to each other in the animal kingdom that
humans are the most cruel beasts no it's
not even not even close
as seen here with this video of a sea
lion and what he does to a girl near the
water in Vancouver British Columbia
let's bring this up not gay Jared so
here look isn't that that's adorable
ah look at you it it looks a little bit
like hopper actor the whiskers want to
cuddle look at him that's a Disney film
kiss he went in for a kiss everyone's
laughing because a good time she feels
so comfortable she's going to turn her
back on the sea lion for the most
violent gets is the rag dolling so much
and by the way for those that you see
otters no okay the male sea otter picks
his mate by biting the female sea otter
and the face clawing her neck and
copulating the life out of her whenever
you see PETA out there with signs saying
save the sea otters there are throngs of
female sea otters saying no no it's like
sleeping with the enemy they're Julia
Roberts just trying to get their swim
away at dusk
but listen for those we never obviously
show anything where someone gets
seriously hurt so not not the hero that
this girl
needed but the one she deserved thank
God dr. David Dowell was there for the
rescue he sued the sea otters family got
15 million serves his purpose all right
so see it in right now this was an
article today not gay Jerry brought up
their bitching about what they're
calling Trump fatigue sorry
and basically the article criticizes
Trump supporters of being numb or
turning off CNN's fake news they
basically admit themselves they are fake
news here's the thing with CNN and we'll
talk something else about to their
collusion with Twitter which i think is
important based on one of what they're
one of the comments from the recent
co-founders recent co-founders one of
the recent comments from their
co-founders struct might a bit I did see
there is basically a campaign to have
Trump impeach that's all it is 24/7
seriously look at the app or the sites
all they do of day and it anyway just
dump dump dump dump well there's there's
a study that just came out the show the
overwhelmingly negative coverage of
Donald Trump yeah and as a matter of
fact they tried to they're like and the
only one who covered Donald Trump
positively was was Fox News though it
depended on the issue that what
journalism is supposed to be what I do
love about the Trump era is that we
talked about that we've talked about
this in the show for so so many years
now where MSNBC everyone knew what I was
always saying CNN is just as bad the
Anderson Cooper's the Don lemons at that
fat gay bald guy who always appears on
there I don't know his name thank
they're worse at this point I'm on the
Trump stuff then Vox Bert worse than hot
did you see Jake Tapper who everyone
really love and respect you haven't
tried to corner Marco Rubio getting him
to speculate bunting capulet Jake Tapper
speculation yeah booboo didn't bite it
in one of the articles they say this in
the Trump fatigue article III thought it
was hilarious they say you know or the
final option what you should do is shut
off your TV turn off your computer take
the Twitter app off your phone and stop
reading anything that starts with Donald
Trump said but as soon as you're in
there
the CNN notification of the Donald Trump
said there's our worst offenders and
we'll get into it more because I want to
get into what happened here with the
Twitter co-founder so Twitter co-founder
Evan Williams by the way his whiskey
sucks that's not true some of its okay
but he said this and I think this is
really alarming okay said I thought once
everybody could speak freely he's
talking about Twitter and exchange
information and ideas the world is
automatically meaning it would
automatically be a better place he told
Washington Times I was wrong about that
so he says here I was wrong about the
idea of a platform that allows for free
speech here's his justification if it's
true that he meaning President Trump
wouldn't be President if it weren't for
Twitter then yeah I'm sorry
think about scary this is for a second
he's saying you know I was wrong I
thought I really supported freedom of
speech I wanted to apply form that was
Pro freedom of speech but I was wrong
not I was wrong because Isis and
radicals have used social media as a
platform or even you know I was wrong
because fake news has become a problem
people just make stuff up and its
clickbait and they make tons of money
lying to people
didgeridoo porn reform you know the
abuse of the boomerang and wonderful
Aboriginal culture not I was wrong about
that he is wrong because he didn't get
precisely the result he wanted in an
election I was wrong about free speech
because my broad didn't win think about
how scary that is for a second they're
willing to completely do a 180 on
something that should be one of the most
fundamental values in your life the
First Amendment is a great divider
before we even get to the second minute
where do you line up on free speech now
Twitter is a business has the right to
do whatever they want but he was saying
the business model was an open platform
and is now saying that's a bad thing
because of President Trump maybe this is
why their Twitter stock is plummeting
that's five days right yeah that's five
days and then that's after we have
that's five years that's like the focus
Study Group when we were watching about
Schmidt and Kathy Bates nude scene shows
up Frank Luntz and his sneakers and
toupee now do you like her breasts or
not I don't know Frank Luntz why do you
have a job so
I just it this just goes to show they
lump everyone into by the way there are
so many Americans out there who hold
pulled you know kind of held their nose
pulled deliver for Donald Trump or so
many Americans who were tired with
brocco I'm a lot of black Americans if
you look at the statistics who voted for
Donald Trump even union workers across
the Rust Belt and people like this on
Twitter they throw that entire voting
base in with Nazis and Pepe the Frog as
though you know what maybe you people
are just bad maybe you're out of maybe
you're wrong and instead of listening
they're going yeah we were wrong about
freedom of speech we were wrong to think
that listening would be good because we
lost now we need to listen less is it me
it's it's scary and that's one thing one
reason I really appreciate Mark Duplass
and coming on come on the shows a guy
who's like hey we lost maybe we should
listen more usually maybe we should
actually talk yeah how dare you I know
the nerve on that boy oh boy all right
final I think we have to before mark
Duplass because we want to bring them
out here before we do that before yeah
we should tease something coming up at
some point what on the CNN note what on
a CNN note that's true what see that's
true by the way we don't know when we
are going to watch CNN for 24 hours in
the coming month a 24 hour livestream of
watching CNN me Anaka Jared you can
watch along with us on that it to prove
the point kind of like Amy Schumer timer
we will have a timer as to how long it
takes before you get into an anti-trump
okay drinking games no he'll be held out
in a stretcher alcohol poisonings a real
stinker if we're doing a drinking game
with water we get water points that's
true all loaded guns will be far far
away from us not within reach 24 hours
knocking Jared and I will watch
continually non-stop nothing but CNN oh
my gosh just so you can see how bad it's
gotten okay final story Clint Eastwood
went on a rant on political correctness
at Cannes Film Festival he said a lot of
people thought it was politically
incorrect regarding Dirty Harry that it
was I said that was the beginning of the
era that were in now where everybody
thinks everyone's politically correct
we're killing ourselves by doing that
we've lost our sense of humor he made
some really valid points that people
should hear unfortunately he made them
to an empty chair so I wish more people
would have been
I hear that I know it's funny we did our
top five films that you can never make
today
you know Blazing Saddles and was number
one but the entire Dirty Harry series
will be included that we included that
you couldn't know it now slap shot
I think with slap shot in there I think
slap shot was in Athens you can go just
run a search if you're watching on
YouTube crowder top five movies and
it'll have top 5 movies that you could
not have made but the entire Dirty Harry
series all the way up to you know sudden
impact could not be made today I mean if
the left today's Hollywood left and they
were always out of touch but of today's
how would the Hollywood left had gotten
their grubby paws on the series you
would have had a very different mr.
Callahan
now I know what you're thinking
this is eating transition or just and
sexual curious tell you the truth given
today's gender spectrum I find it hard
to tell myself but given that any
assault on me would count as an extra
hate crime with additional 10 years
punishable in prison just on account of
the Rouge you have to ask yourself one
question
when I feel tolerant
well
yeah
Hey
that's to know
Oh
I'm just
Oh The Forgotten just traditional gay we
don't even think about them anymore I
actually think I like that version of
Dirty Harry you can put us if you want
them back we have mark Duplass coming up
next stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]
do me in
is blackjack your game it's not so much
my game as it seemed my kind of place
I'll stay you sure you don't want to try
for more well when I see something I
like I know how to hang on to it
interesting philosophy
what can you tell me about that mug Club
I'm just a girl hit me are you sure
that's what you want positive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright there we gonna have to let pogo
play out everyone loves Pogo and
actually I will tell you this
we've probably gotten more positive
feedback on an interview with this next
gentleman this guy you said when you get
recognized all the time like a week ago
even someone recognized me and this is
the interview they brought up said I
really liked that interview with with
this guy I'll let you well I hope he has
the same feedback I hope people were
kind and positive with him at mark
Duplass on twitter and his uh his show
on HBO I believe I have this like room
104 is coming out soon right that's
right room 104 um well there I'm really
glad to have you back I know it sounds
like it warms my heart but like I'm glad
to always have someone who with a
differing opinion come back in a
friendly atmosphere
did you receive mostly positive feedback
from the last time you were on I gotta
say I'm not putting a shine on and it
was incredibly positive you know I got a
couple of people and I'm it was 50/50
couple of people from the right just
extremely upset with me just because of
the nature of my existence of my views
and I don't think they could transcend
the fact that my profile is that of an
extremely like out of touch Hollywood
person right and so and by the way fine
I can I can handle that and then I also
got some stuff from the left being like
hey you can't go on Crowder and
normalize these types of opinions by
being friendly to them and that's not
okay which I totally disagree with but
I'm like I understand I respect that
opinion so that was pretty minimal
but overall the thing that I really got
was like hey man don't agree with you at
all but really appreciate you coming and
having a civil conversation and I'd like
to see what you're up to and and and in
particular you know next time you sort
of start one of your charity campaigns
as long as it's like a pretty you know
bipartisan cause I'm in I'm there to
help so that was very encouraged I'm
glad to see that I also got thousands of
comments of people saying they hated me
because they watched creep that night
and then they get so fat that obviously
the bigger of a great performance but I
can't type you were like screw you I
hate you you may be watch creep and I
can't because everyone has a friend like
that
I remember my friend let's call him Adam
madam and it was like oh you wish she
gets a friend just not you uh everyone
have that friend so I'm glad to hear
that and then after that you would on
Dave Rubin show it did this correctly
you're you're going to Africa with Glenn
Beck or something yeah I went to I went
on Reuben Reuben I had a great
conversation Reuben and I are obviously
a lot closer in our core values I didn't
word that that was going to be an issue
and then went on Glenn Beck who I found
truly fascinating he reached out to me
and you know I guess that I wasn't
paying close enough attention on kind of
like the the shifts he was going through
as a person yeah and my feeling was just
like oh this guy has had a really hard
time in life and is now much less
confident in his theories and it's much
more open as to what's going to work and
and we had fun I think we had a lot of
fun realizing that like if we had chosen
to talk about abortion we would be
screaming at each other right but we
found a couple connection points we're
both big charity guys and and you know
I'm I am essentially a libertarian when
it comes to my business you know I look
at Hollywood like the government I'm
like get out of my face yeah I want to
do my own thing and we connected on that
and and so so yeah so he's a real
creative type too I think a lot of
people don't realize about about Glenn
Beck you know he was kind of put into a
AM radio became so much of a box I mean
we were on radio for all to know I said
okay screw it because it is very OneNote
and you get that whether it's MSNBC or
CNN you know on the left and then on the
right it gets to this you know red meat
I don't like you liberals and I know
people like Glenn Beck kind of felt like
they were put in that box and we've
always managed to just break outside
that box and then the sand goes
everywhere and generate no revenue but
I'm glad to hear that you know here's
one thing I find interesting that you
say that from the left because I've
gotten that a lot really like you can't
normalize his views yeah I don't know
what views I hold that are ones that
shouldn't be normalized for example yeah
I understand you probably shouldn't go
on a neo-nazi show who actually believes
in murdering people who aren't white or
something like that but I've never had a
leftist actually capable to point to my
views which are so extreme that that
couldn't be normalized if they give you
any like specifics or just don't do it
no no no and just in all fairness
both of those extremist opinions I got
felt like quite honestly people who were
just knee-jerk reaction and maybe even
trying to get me to respond to them on
Twitter yeah some people kind of poked
me on purpose just so they like hey mark
Duplass wrote to me you know so I didn't
get the sense that that was like an
extremely well vet vetted and
thought-out opinion sure I think it's
quite honestly what you represents to
the left if someone is an extremist
leftist and they look at you know your
feed on Twitter or something like that
they're just gonna pick up on those
little nuggets sure that is catchy
things get people to watch the show and
they're gonna think that that
encapsulate cyou yeah and you thusly
defined and they don't want to deal with
you and you know I mean I get that from
the write a little bit but it's not
that's I don't if I go on a leftist show
um I the criticism I get from the right
is never you shouldn't do that show it's
hey that guy is wrong about you should
have called him out on this that or the
other thing whereas I have heard from
most liberal guests who come on the show
and this is the problem that I think we
see that I would say is it kind of
exclusive to the left and that is you
shouldn't have this conversation at all
because that's never the criticism I get
for having you on the show or going on
Reubens show or something like that I
feel that's very different reaction well
you know what now that you say that and
to be more clear the point is not it's
not so much that I came at all it's that
you let him express all these views and
you didn't word him up as a true
representative of the left so I get it's
it is somewhat similar to what you're
talking about it is like how could you
just accept that and listen and validate
that when for me like as a person who's
been to therapy and isn't a marriage
like validation is everything that's how
I get by and all of my relationships
like I look at so many political
arguments right now and I'm just like
it's it's been very interesting as I've
gone through this process as an
extremely uneducated person in politics
in general like I'm just leaning into
this as a hobby and I'm on a
fact-finding mission as opposed to a
like let me show you what's up and how
to do it and and over the last like two
months or so I've learned like kind of
incredible things that that have been I
don't know like I've
a lot of my own personal blind spots on
some stuff so that's been good do you
mean specific that you would say was
like a blind spot I mean not to put you
on the spot at all like in terms of
specific blind spots like one great one
that I got mostly from Twitter from
people on the right was like why don't
people on the left support veterans
what's the issue here you know and I
thought about it and my initial reaction
was to get the fence and be like I like
veterans and we do and then I thought
about it I was like you know what a lot
of liberals really don't you hear them
championing causes you hear them
chanting charities and they don't do
stuff for veterans and I realized what
it was I think is that veterans get
grouped up unfairly with this whole
support of the military which the left
is traditionally saying why can't we
give more money to education to arts
education and schools why are we giving
so much to military spending yeah and
fortunately the like for because they're
not thinking about it deeply enough like
veterans are caught up in that so that
was a really great blind spot that was
called on me and I was like you're right
so now I'm like let me try and find a
really good veteran bipartisan cause and
I can't we run a charitable campaign on
likewise as I when I would say this too
actually as far as a blind spot on the
right I think and we've seen it with
people who we see it all the time there
is constant corruption with veteran
charities in the right because their
right is so quick to give money to
veterans causes and a lot of the time
people take advantage of that and so
this idea if you go away home a second I
support the veterans or even I support
the war but I don't support this
specific organization people will jump
on you from the right and and that's a
that's an area where we've gotten flack
for we've even gotten flack as huge
Second Amendment people for example
talking about certain gun organizations
going on a second these maybe aren't the
organizations you want to support and
they take that as an attack on the idea
so I think wait yeah and then you know I
kind of I got into a lot of it like
America first type discussions because
you know we talked about this a little
bit last time like her my kind of
personal feeling I'm just like you know
it's not just your neighbor it's
everybody we're in a global environment
and and one thing that was a real easy
blind spot that I caught on at least
some of my fans on the right was like
you know but why are you not giving more
money to people at home
when there's so many problems at home
why are you trying to do all these
international charity works like what
are you doing we gotta we gotta like to
fix our stuff here sure how and and so I
was able to cross the aisle and a really
good clean water cause and it was like
okay people on the right generally want
to know that like we're giving fishing
poles we're not giving fish we're giving
charity wanted to be a sustainable
system that's not gonna create
dependence on us right and it's like
okay so these clean water charities are
a perfect thing you go and you install a
clean water system from a poop you walk
away it's there it's great
so I ran something I ran a campaign on
that we raised like ten thousand dollars
and I got a ton of support from the
right on that which is really great so
that was like a big thing was just like
okay if you're not super defensive about
your blind spots stuff can work out
pretty well let me ask you this do you
feel as though no I would argue from a
factual stand where there's a book
called who really cares by uh David
Brooks I think my David Brooks and it
talks about people who give and
conservative Christians actually just
tend to be the most charitable and this
is not a concern I that you would say
that Arthur Brooks Arthur Brooks David
Brooks is the New York Times guy I
always get them mixed up but um it's
interesting you say that do you think
this is maybe open your eyes to this
idea again we've always talked about
this just sort of questioning intent you
see a lot from from we say from the left
and I would stand on that position and
if you think I'm wrong you can tell me
why but a lot of times well why don't
you care about X has this maybe opened
your eyes that actually conservative
Christian red state countries seem to
care more in a willing to part with
their dollars more just not by force do
you feel that's an accurate assessment
oh yeah I mean from what I can tell when
I can hear that seems to be pretty
broadly accepted whether it's true or
not that seems to be the thing that
people are saying which is just like why
are you forcing me to give to this
organization
please tax me less I'm a generous person
and some version of either trickle-down
economics because I have more money I'll
put it into the economy it'll feed
everything or because I have more money
you didn't tax me I am now free to give
more rive yeah I hear that a lot yeah
yeah and not just I think in by force
but we really care about the effect of
this a lot that's why yeah that's why
cuz service omeka service have
problems with the we're welfare state
the way it is if we see a an
effectiveness leak yeah well that's the
issue it's not I think we talked about
this even with stefan molyneux who was
an atheist for example he's a very he's
an atheist philosopher but he actually
said i actually find that i like
christians more as today's a because
atheist tend to be very aggressive and
unemployed and he's an atheist but he
said also it's just they're willing to
go through the process even if we come
to different conclusions and I think
contrast and when I talk about the left
maybe you saw that tweet right after
Roger Ailes died by the way we had
written like five Roger Ailes jokes
hilarious we just didn't use him like
well that's tasteless but there were
jokes
whereas chanc Weger when I use terms
like the left came out and said I'm glad
he had those two extra years so he could
die alone humiliated and destitute and
the spirit of that is just so much
meaner and I feel as though that's more
extract accepted on the mainstream
leftist the spirit of idiot
you dumbass you don't care it's okay as
long as we're winning mm-hmm so I have a
couple of thoughts on that know what
getting a general vibe based on our
whole conversation here and the tone of
how this is going that like when I feel
from you in a very respectful way and a
very gentle way is you're ready to
engage in a debate with me on how the
left is actually behaving in bad ways
and you're ready to stand in some
positions that are saying left behaving
worse than people on the right a couple
of times and you know what you may very
well be right and my position is I'm
actually not in a position from a state
of being as educated you are politically
about all these things
sure or do I have the interest actually
in engaging in it because what's
happening to me lately and look you can
you can disagree with this or not what's
happening to me lately aware I'm finding
my place
is of interest to me and that people
responding to is just as simple as as I
can possibly say is in ferreting out
similarities and and not differences and
this has been the most exciting thing to
me and I and I bring it up in reference
to
you know the Glenn Beck situation where
I was just like dude if he and I
wouldn't go I mean we can go at it all
day long we're specially or spelling or
whatever it is what I found really
fascinating and what I'm trying to dial
in right now is this kind of new form of
debate and and Glenn and I are setting
up a couple of speaking engagements to
this tune which is basically saying like
okay it's very easy for us to get into a
room and talk about why we think one
side is behaving worse than the other or
why one side is maybe more right than
the other what if we got to a place
where we said okay what if we try to
cobble together some ideas and try and
build upon what we know from each side
of an argument upon a system that
doesn't work on either side for instance
welfare
whoever's whoever's running it with the
government right it's the light or the
left it's just not working so what if
the what if the form of debate was well
I don't have the answers and you don't
have the answers maybe we could try and
and build something together and try and
hold on some ideas this is the thing
that I have discovered through this
process that is the most interesting to
me and I don't know how that resonates
with you and that's okay I agree with
that not I'm not looking for I was
asking because of kind of the reaction
that you you mentioned coming off of the
last show and the reaction of some of
those people yeah and the reaction that
we've gotten like I said this last week
has just been exhausting I'm it's just
in politics it's not fun for anyone on
either side I'm sure we could finally I
would say I am willing to write off the
percentage of extremists on the left who
come at me and say any of those things
you're talking about being a little more
vitriolic and they should a little more
reactionary ready to just like call
anyone a racist Zenith xenophobe
homophobic person when they say one
thing wrong or to your points make
tasteless jokes about Roger Ailes it's
death likewise I am willing to write off
someone on the right who comes at me and
discredit anything I say or do because I
want to support Planned Parenthood and
just saying your and baby killer go to
hell and die yeah I'm not really going
to be able to engage no you're not and
any and I will tell you this I mean well
here's the thing let me ask you this
because what you said I think there are
common grounds but it's sort of
predicated on the idea that both people
said well maybe you don't have the
answers and I don't have the answers
let's build something what if someone
respectfully says
I do think I have some of the answers
and would point to it for example I
think Planned Parenthood is an example
they we talked about this they don't
provide mammograms they cannot provide
breast cancer screenings it's just they
never have they never will they can't
and they actually don't provide the
majority of women's health care in the
country so I would say an answer for
example this would be an answer coming
from the right respectful in other words
I'm starting off saying okay it's not
neither one of us have the answers I
think I haven't answer and you can tell
me you think it's wrong conservatives do
not have a problem with giving funding
to other crisis pregnancy centers or
Pregnancy Resource Center's that don't
perform abortions and there are more
than of those yeah would that not be
something that people could find I mean
common ground if again we're not even
talk about removing the public funding
at this point just let's just put it
into places where they don't actually
perform the abortion services yeah I
mean look it's it's a very rational
argument you know none of those
organizations are and to my knowledge
are as big and have as much reach as
parent Planned Parenthood does you know
when you're dealing with like three to
four percent of the services of Planned
Parenthood actually go towards abortion
I would say that like those other
services are worthwhile and they aren't
worth defunding but I understand one
issue voting you know like and I
understand I'm the last person who's
gonna come up and say like if you are
truly a pro-life person it's really hard
for me to stand and say like you should
absolutely vote for the support of
Planned Parenthood I get why don't and
I'm okay with that
well let me and this is not to argue
about it cuz my wife that's what she
does she works in a crisis pregnancy
center volunteers actually should say
and we were just talk about this the
other day you know the most common no
one doesn't know about birth control
2017 as a matter of fact in the year
she's done it it's never happened once
that someone didn't know they knew they
decided not to use it for whatever
reason often a man is pressuring a woman
into an abortion it will come to this
clinic and they've talked about how easy
it is to get women to have the child or
to give it up for adoption just as easy
as it would be to veer them toward
abortion they come in and they're
looking for a decision to make and these
crisis pregnancy centers legally they
are not allowed to tell someone this is
what you do as a matter of fact all they
do is provide resources and facts if a
woman has an ultrasound nine
that attention isn't get the abortion
anymore she knows that there's a beating
heart at I think six weeks they don't
know they inform them with these kind of
they give them this kind of information
but D she would planned parented for
example this is where not to fact-check
anyone but um this idea that three four
percent are only abortions it's it's not
true and they're going and the reason
for that this is again where I would say
conservatives are saying hey we can find
common ground by giving it to other
organizations you know if you go in for
an abortion to Planned Parenthood Abby
Johnson wrote a great book on this she
was a former worker there if you go in
you have an examination let's say you
have some kind of a pap smear or they
give you a prescription you meet with a
doctor the five all of these are done to
perform an abortion that could be
counted as five or seven services even
though every single one of those
services was an auxilary service to the
abortion even though it's an abortion
that would count as one out of seven
services and so they do trick the
numbers because the vast majority of
their actual money comes from abortions
and that's why we have a problem tonight
um it's the big-ticket item and if
they're just as incentivized to push
people to the big-ticket item as my wife
is to push people away from it and I
would like I think that's a place where
we could find common ground even if
we're not pro-life like hey we just
don't want to be paying for it right I
totally understand your point I hear you
I feel like we are more entering the
realm that is something where it's just
like I think it needs to be okay you say
not to fact-check and you fact check me
that's fact-checking so I think it's I
think it's helping to educate because
that's why people may be so defensive on
the right because they hit for example
they hear talking points so often and
when we know it not to be true
um and I don't think that you know it
not I I don't think you're an ignorant
person I don't think you're not an
educated person I just think it's
something they throw out so often then
if you don't do more than a glance it's
easy to accept it and I think that's
more important than just saying hey
let's meet in the middle is if someone
says well on a second what if that is
incorrect and then meeting together on
you know agreeing on the actual
information that that is my goal listen
I I hear you and and I think it's
totally fine for you and I to have
different agendas in terms of like what
we're about you know because for my my
personal perspective like there's
when I feel the response from people in
terms of what is effective right now
like and what you felt last time was
like you felt probably zero resistance
from me coming in and trying to listen
and try and like hear some things of you
and I think that that was really
eye-opening to your audience that like
anyone from the left could do that
because it's quite frankly I think that
we are so dug in right now we are so
extremely vitriolic that anytime that
there's an open and listening energy
it's just extremely powerful and so
there's a documentary on Netflix that I
would would encourage you to watch or
encourage any of your viewers to watch
it's really fascinating
it's called accidental courtesy okay so
there's not a bodyguard film of Justin
Bieber's bodyguards those the worst
documentary I thought there's no way
they can make this boring they did
documentary so there's a guy named Daryl
Davis he's a black musician from oh yes
I watched this yes go ahead okay so what
he does is for those who haven't seen it
is he befriends members of the Ku Klux
Klan and he doesn't sit with them and
tell them in respectful intelligent
debate and with data why they should not
be a part of the Ku Klux Klan and he
doesn't even use his knowledge to
convince them which I think pretty much
everybody can get on board with that
judging a whole group of people by their
skin color and assuming they're terrible
people is just not a great use of time
and energy and a super educated way to
go about life it's bad he doesn't do any
of that he sits with them he has drinks
with them he listens to them he doesn't
challenge them and he befriends them and
now he has a closet full of Ku Klux Klan
memorabilia and Ku Klux Klan robes from
these members of the Ku Klux Klan he is
befriended and he was never once tried
to out debate never once tried to prove
that they're wrong even gently and they
have left by sheer example and that is
like in my opinion that's some Jesus
levels right there I mean that is
it's impressive stuff and I'm never
gonna be that person and I don't know
how to be that person because quite
frankly I'm lucky I don't have to face
that kind of persecution but that has
been such a strong example to me of what
a what a powerful version in my opinion
what I'm looking for is in debate
because I'm I have a lot of friends on
the left that I have a lot of
conversations with you know sure and
ulema just like dude what are you doing
you're like wasting your time you're not
arguing positions you're not trying to
pull people over and I'm like I'm not
going on Crowder to tell him that he's
wrong and to pull him over I'm going on
crowd or to open my mind to listen to
him to hear what he had to say about
Planned Parenthood he's trying to soak
some of that in see if I can get
educated see if I can find another blind
spot of my own so I can grow as a person
and quite possibly more importantly to
show some of his fan base that yes there
are people on the Left who are willing
to listen and bye I guess but I think
it'd be okay if you if you challenge me
on something put it this way you can
always feel free to and I want this to
be a binary you can do both well no I
just I wanted to be different because I
think a lot of other people are afraid
to and again I wasn't trying to
challenge it's just that's information
that that I you know for example that a
lot of people don't know but I would you
know I think when you'll read up you go
oh my god this is this is right I also
feel there's the first rung of the
ladder and that's kind of the first time
on the show someone with Ruben I go oh
we don't hate each other and I think
people also need to be okay okay there's
ring too
no not not dig in but like you told me
about the veteran thing I think that's
on the right we're like I said people
are exploited on the right on the flip
side with Rob yeah I mean listen there's
a worked at Fox News for years right
they put an American flag behind
something and sometimes it is really
easy to fool people into some sense of
patriotism where you and I would agree
and and I actually I'm fine with being
challenged on those things um as long as
it's you know in a respectful civil way
and and my because if ever you think I'm
wrong or your friends think I'm wrong
yes yes I would like to hear I would
like to hear my him blind spots as well
and the problem is we either get someone
like you who's just so nice and you
listen and if we're both let just
listening and nothing happened
and then there are people who are just
so angry just come on and say oh you're
a baby killer because you support guns
so I'd like to show to be a balance of
all about isn't to your request here's
just a gentle challenge do you think
that someone who is a trans person might
take offense at the word [ __ ] at all I
think some of them absolutely would yeah
and we've had people on the show who
call themselves [ __ ] mm-hmm so so
how do you feel like using that word
what's your sense of that um that's a
good question
especially because I think I think you
understand through the spirit we don't
do things just to hurt people there are
some people on the right who just do
things to hurt people but I come from
the Lenny Bruce school of thought and
you know the great performance from
Dustin Hoffman you know don't take my
words away yeah you can't take the word
I don't know if it is that's I haven't
seen a long time it's Dustin Hoffman
doing Lenny Bruce so we're thrice
removed so I am very very reserved when
it comes to taking words off the table
especially as a comedian because I saw
people I mean a comedian - friend of
mine named Mike in Montreal left-wing
vegan and we actually would do colleges
together and he had a bit where use the
word [ __ ] and never at any point was
it considered hateful so this kind of
removing people's words until we're
standing on this little plot of land I
do make that that I think that's more of
a moral stand to say no we're not going
to concede that then can see each word
that might be offensive so but it's a
valid question is there any credence to
the argument and I actually like I don't
feel the need to strongly make this
argument but someone I know a lot of
people who would make the argument like
there was a time when the word [ __ ]
was totally comfortable to be used and
then we learned that like this was a
civil rights movement these were people
that needed to be validated and that
didn't need to be labeled as such with
the derogatory words so we came up with
new words and then they became an
equally remember you know respected part
of society and that and that worked out
there are a lot of people in the trans
movement who would say listen this is
group that has been persecuted and been
made fun of and joked about they're not
really a Titan of industry that needs to
be jabbed and joked and taken down
they're a group that's like having a
hard time and could be lifted up and it
might be not a bad thing to be
respectful and give them the terminology
that they prefer even if that has
changed over the last well when they
come on the show we actually we just we
just used neutral anything because the
truth is I'm liable to screw up when I
have a guy with mascara on a lipstick
who looks like a guy with a 5 o'clock
shadow I'm much more likely to say he
now we've had Blair white in the show
who looks very much like a woman my
natural inclination is to say she so
literally I'm not someone who dies and
that he'll we're like well Caitlyn
Jenner he let's be honest okay we're not
all in on this verbal contract and it's
really easy to screw up so I'm just not
gonna give the leeway and if I had
someone said hey don't call me a [ __ ]
that's fine by me you aware that [ __ ]
was disrespectful to some people I'm
aware that it's offensive yeah even when
we play spot the [ __ ] and we played it
with a [ __ ] I am but I think the
comparison to the N word I think it's
invalid for a couple of reasons
and I would say invalid for mainly
reasons that stem from the left sort of
kneecapping their own arguments because
it's an idea of gender fluidity
well there's gender fluidity then it's
kind of you know like the whole I was
born this way it will actually it's the
opposite you're saying that someone
can't be born into a male brain but
they're born into a female brain it's
actually gender fluid that people can
can choose they're not only sexuality
but they're gender on a day to day basis
and there are 52 different genders that
can't be ready to Ala T well this is
pansexual that you can shoot you can
flip your sexuality day to day I mean ha
footers had a recent article about it
and you can also flip your gender day to
day and I think that comes with a litany
of questions well can I change my gender
enough to apply for a woman scholarship
grant and then switch back I mean this
is the kind these are questions and I
think that um it's a it's an important
there's certainly room for that system
in that like you can't criticize me
because I am a yeah of some sort to for
abuse of that system yeah I just don't
think it's I can get away with a lot
here because of that and I think that's
a fair point well we did an experiment
with that we're knocking cheering I went
to a mall where he just has a gig
said the exact same thing that I said is
a straight guy they called the cops on
me and they thought he was adorable you
know for example he just walked up but
he said can I can I just say your tits
are to die for
I was like and I just walked up and
don't fix it can I just say your your
tits are to die for
and wasn't the same exact reaction it
was funny though but yeah I don't think
it's standard or that yeah I don't think
it's valid comparison because he can't
choose race and I think that's a word
that was designed specifically if you
look at the history of the n-word
designed specifically to demean and make
someone subhuman [ __ ] was a
colloquialism that they coined
themselves and they've now decided to
change it as a political weapon they
weaponize words at worst they don't
think the n-word was weaponized by the
victims initially as as a word it was
used by the oppressors and I think it's
a very distinct history difference there
that's just it might take note yeah well
you know I would say that you know not a
not a big one but like if you're looking
for accessibility I don't know even that
you are but if you looking accessibility
on that joke you're looking for
everybody to lean in on it when a
Twitter headline doesn't say [ __ ] in
it you'll get probably further in terms
of people being able laugh at it you
know yeah most of our most of our
Twitter stories with trainees who
actually include trainees that are on
the show yeah who call themselves that
so but no I agree with you I agree with
you listen there's some times like for
example you know jokes about Roger Ailes
and sexual harassment going up in hell
these are also not going to be the most
accessible at we acknowledge that's the
fine line I would agree with you between
comedy and trying to reach across the
aisle and we try to walk it fairly mr.
du plus we have to go always want to
have you back and listen always if ever
you think even I'm wrong or you just
want to talk or ask a question we really
want to be to all of it if it's just
listening and have a conversation great
and if it's calling me out or I also
want that all of it as welcome here and
I would be interested in if you are and
we could try this some other time is
like you know finding a system even if
you think you have really good ideas but
that you're not a hundred percent sure
you have the right answer on and that
could be something as simple as like
health care because it's so complex oh
well whatever it is and then maybe you
and I could like pickin a sub
and see if we could go in on it together
okay and teach each other some things
about what we like what we don't see if
something could be built that's like
kind of interesting to me it might be
boring but I mean how about this how
about this because every now and then
with patrick moore the founder of
greenpeace in ecology in atmospheric
science sorry a PhD in ecology we did an
hour with him we're gonna do an hour
with professor Jordan Peterson this week
let's say let's aim for somewhere in
three to four weeks we'll actually just
do the full show the full it's a about
an hour and let's agree on some topics
and do that if you want that sounds
great to me it'll be interesting yeah it
sounds I really appreciate it brother
brother brother mark honestly I was
looking forward to having you on and and
it really does we all get a sense of it
gets we get warm and fuzzies thinking
about hey we don't have that everyone
has to hate each other mr. Crowder you
are my son and I love thank you very
much and room 104 on AC I look at that a
plug right a miss birthday class we'll
be back music playing
many of you are still unaware of the
items available at louder with Crowder
shop calm not only do they make you look
and feel better but they serve a
multitude of purposes like our socialism
is for [ __ ] shirts
assisting in identifying potential
allies I think it's pretty funny or our
bad hombres firearm t-shirt helping you
know who to avoid I might have take that
shirt to mean you support some kind of
firearm registry or this one hey look
it's my face I hate it though louder
with Crowder shop calm isn't for
everyone but can i buy the mug from the
shop without joining the Month Club no
the rest of you check out the
merchandise at Lauder with craters shop
calm today
[Music]
glad to have you mark Duplass that Wow
lovely was hope we have him back you
know what actually I think I will do
with mark Duplass him and I will pick a
few topics where we can actually go over
talk about them but also have some
points and counter points and respectful
arena maybe do it live in person for a
charity that we both agree on it could
be like st. Jude's or something like
that so if you want to see that really
him at mark Duplass me at s crowd or
maybe not at not gay Jarrod can moderate
or whoever mark Duplass wants but always
let it have him back and I think we're
actually on have Laci green on the
program sister bring Sally cone back by
the way if you know people out there who
are who are left who are willing to come
on the show we are always happy to host
them that's a big part of this program
it's just really hard to book them yeah
it's really hard to book them tomorrow
we have Gavin McGinnis we are going to
do a one-hour special with Jordan
Peterson on Wednesday and then on
Thursday we're going to have Tommy
Lauren live in studio which is her first
kind of live in studio full interview
since some of the controversies yeah so
that'll be she'll be right here and this
in this chair that's alright right there
in that chair that's not designed to be
the leg chair no tell me Lorraine so um
we'll see you tomorrow on YouTube by the
way this is this is the full free week
for people who are not mug club members
this show happens every single day
whether you want it to or not at CR
tv.com lot of credit calm slash mug club
it is $99 annually $69 for students
veterans or active military you get a
hand etched mug and you get this show
every day along with Mark Levine Michele
milk and gosh I don't know a handful
more shows and a whole bunch coming down
the pipeline a lot of people especially
since YouTube has been doing what
they're doing there are a lot of people
who are going to be linked enough arms
here and of course you also get morning
grinders not just you're in court Friday
so we'll see you tomorrow on YouTube 9
p.m. every single night and then
Thursday the livestream at 8:00 as per
usual tomorrow gather McGinnis
[Music]